[Music]
today's question comes from debbie in
los angeles she said my husband and i
have two hundred and thirty thousand
dollars in our 401k we switched to a
money market plan about seven years ago
because we're both in our mid-50s good
lord the cfo at his work is now trying
to convince him to go back into mutual
funds he went as far as to tell him that
we missed out on 59 000 in 2021 he's
right
i'm not buying it we lost almost all of
our 401k in 2008 with this man telling
us it would go back up and to stop
watching it i don't want to ever watch
that train wreck again why would the cfo
be pushing for us to risk our retirement
fund
oh boy where to start with debbie sweet
debbie sweet little debbie little dude
all right well
he's got a cake
i'm with the cfo on this one i think
he's trying to help you retire with
dignity and not lose out big because you
jumped off the roller coaster mid-ride
and clearly their spook day from 2008
which is understandable
but to be in a money market account
which means it's just sitting in cash
for seven years
losing against inflation making zero
percent that's a bad plan if you want to
retire ever
all right debbie
you can't win at investing being drama
debbie
and you're being drama debbie you did
not lose your entire 401k in 2008. the
stock market did not go to zero
it went in half
and so
if you took out
if you had four hundred thousand dollars
at the beginning and you moved it to
money markets at the very bottom which
makes you the world's worst timing
then you've got 230 000 so that means
you lost half of your money
you can't say
we lost almost all no you did not not if
you were in a mutual fund it's actually
mathematically impossible that you would
have lost almost all of it there is not
a group of mutual funds that suck that
bad
that it went down 90 while the market
went down
50 it went from the dow went from 13 000
to 6 hundred
i know i was there my investments did
the exact same thing i was here on the
radio sounding just exactly like your
cfo
don't jump off the train no one gets
hurt
except those that jump off in the middle
of a roller coaster ride the ride to the
end now if you had not dropped off
jumped off the train at the bottom you
would not have lost half of your money
because in just a few months
the dow was back to where it was
pre-2008 oh by the way it was at 13 000
then it went to 6500
you know it's over 30 000 a day debbie
and so you would have had not 200 000
you would have had 1.2 million right now
if you had 230 000 at the bottom in 2008
and you left it in there you'd have 1.2
million right now you didn't lose 59 000
debbie you lost a million dollars
ouch
you're being a debbie downer dave i want
you to know that i'm downing debbie
that's me
uh debbie we're just having some fun
here we're picking on you but
anyway that's the math i mean it's true
that's exactly people are scared to
invest i don't know um
with this man telling us it would go
back up and to stop watching it well i
don't think he has any ulterior motives
went back up debbie um the cfo's not
making money from you being in a mutual
fund or in the 401k
cfos don't get commissions on 401ks
none whatsoever he's just trying to help
and the way that he's trying to give you
the essence and the nuances of the
market and so
um and then the market's back down it's
tr it's trashed right now it's it's
horrible right this second
and um i mean
yeah yeah
you everybody's employed and nobody's
making money in the stock market biden
could screw up christmas but um the uh
yeah but but doesn't matter you know
what i'm doing this month i'm not taking
it out it's on sale debbie
ukraine
uh elon musk is buying the world
uh
what else is going wrong with the world
oh inflation oh that's right uh
gas housing market you name it president
cancering a sentence together uh
yeah i mean these are the things that
are happening out there and so the stock
market's going i'm so scared and it's
going down right so you know what i'm
doing
investing you know what i do when it
goes up invest you know what i do when
it goes down i invest why because the
worst movement in the stock market's
history other than the great depression
was 2008 and debbie apparently if i'm
reading this right you managed to take
your money out at the exact worst time
i mean you you really hit it
amazingly bad
so you panicked at exactly the wrong
time you should have panicked earlier or
later or something but oh my gosh what's
the quote it's uh not about timing the
market it's time in the market it's
consistency yeah exactly just leave it
alone keep investing yeah you would you
lost out on 59 000 in 2021
but you've probably lost close to a
million dollars if you took this out at
the bottom
of the crash after 08 and moved it to
money markets and have made no money on
it since meanwhile my money's gone up 5
x
5x
since the bottom of the 2008 crash
really almost 6x technically
i mean the dial is down a little bit
right now but i mean it was up to 38 000
which would have been 6x oh yeah so um
so that's why debbie that's why because
you're not really risking your
retirement fund if you quit taking it
out at the bottom you're risking not
being able to retire when you get 200
000 at retirement yeah
i mean let look at this okay here's
another thing this is for everybody
we're using debbie as an example bless
your heart but you walked into a debbie
so
um
if the analysis i gave you is exactly
half wrong
in my case i'm i'm i'm half i'm off by
50
in the little math formula i just did on
the air okay which i'm not but let's
just say i'm off by that much
and you didn't have a million too
you're off by 50 you'd have 600 000.
it's still almost three times more than
you've got today
so this would have your cfo would have
had been
dramatically drastically wrong
like
wrong by thousands of percent
for you to end up with less than you do
now yeah
that's why he would be pushing for you
to risk your retirement fund uh you are
perceiving more risk with your emotions
than are is actually mathematically
there that's what we're saying that's
the summary and if i'm debbie i'm
sitting down with a smartvestor pro to
educate myself on what would have
happened if i left my money there
ride the ride educate myself on what i'm
actually investing in so i can make that
decision right now she needs that kind
of coach she's freaked out
yeah and you know george that um thing
we're talking about the other day there
is a mutual fund
that opened in
in 1934
it has averaged
since 1934 12.25
interest a rate of return
the number of years 87 years has been
open the number of times it's been down
16.
wow
16 years out of 87 it was down
the other year 71 years it was up
so that's the type of thing that should
be in your in your mutual funds in your
401k
and that's even safer than the market
yeah you gotta have a long-term mindset
this is the ramsey show